necesita que el parlamento apruebe el
plan de gestión y eso le permita al
presidente pedro castillo ejecutar
políticas de desarrollo reactivar la
economía hacer un mejor manejo de la
pandemia entre otras políticas de estado
para esto se necesitan seis votos que
otorgarían la investidura al gabinete de
la primera ministra de mirtha vásquez si
esto no se consigue la primera ministra
tendría que renunciar el presidente
pedro casi o dominar a un nuevo gabinete
y repetir todo el proceso de investidura
llevar al parlamento a los ministros con
todo lo que esto demore debemos señalar
que la antigua legislación el cielo en
el congreso es censura va o negar el
voto de confianza dos gabinetes
consecutivos el presidente tenía la
facultad constitucional de disolver lo
de cerrarlo pero como hace unos días
atrás el de este parlamento modificó la
legislatura pedro castillo se encuentra
debilitado políticamente y sometido a
las decisiones que decida ejercer el
congreso sobre él y su gobierno y hasta
este momento como se ve el panorama
entre los congresistas cuáles escenarios
se podrían presentar
bueno le cuento que es el momento en la
derecha que domina el parlamento
adelantado que van a negar el voto de
confianza a la primer ministra mirtha
vásquez mientras tanto en la otra acera
la bancada oficialista de perú libre
está dividida entre quienes respaldarán
al gabinete gobierno y otros no es ahí
también los partidos otros partidos de
izquierda quienes dicen que van a
respaldar la gestión a todo esto podemos
señalar que la sesión va a durar de
largo hasta la noche y en caso se niegue
la confianza podría producirse lo que se
denomina en la primer revés del
presidente pedro casi o ante el
parlamento acá se podrían presentar los
escenarios uno que el parlamento consiga
los votos niegue la confianza y el otro
escenario en el cual no se consigan los
votos para negar la investidura del
gabinete en este caso lo que mencionan
algunos analistas es que van a dar la
confianza al gabinete y posteriormente
van a programar sesiones de
interpelación y esto después caería
destituir a algunos ministros que el
parlamento no considere debe estar el
gobierno y así tratar de ejercer un
dominio o manejo a la gestión de pedro
castillo